Is this good enough quality???
Okay, let's...let's start the match
What a great point! Hehe. That's how you do it!
We'll...we'll put a table there after this first game.
That's a good one.
Oooh...
The serving...
The edge. The edge guy.
Okay. First set, 11:9 to Otto.
To make *indistinguishable*. Good shots, good placement, and that's the first point.
Emil: Whoa nice backhand Otto. Otto: That's my favourite shot.
Is this going to Otto?
1:2
What a backhand!!! That was a great backhand.
Okay, 3:7.
Good push.
But now 8:3.
It's good strawberry now it's off the serving deal
By the way, yeah, it's it's super warm in this hall. It's play here
Good shot good shot
Can he kill the points?
Yes, he can. Oh. did it touch? did it touch?
Miikka: Was it in or out?
Okay, the umpire is giving point to Otto. That touched. Lucky , lucky one. Really don't know
The Second Game
And there we go
What happened there? Miikka leading 8:3 three and then it went to 11:8.
It's actually not a white shirt that I was wearing. It's a pink
Which I'll it just looks like a white one from the video
1:1
Okay, sorry now they visible again
And playin a lot or a few more
On a basic level. That's a good point again
Send the hello to Brazil. Hello guys. Can he now keep the hippest lead?
7:3. Okay, what's now gonna happen??? Some lobbing?
The edge they load to the call timeout
Good serve
What's happening now?
Board game points
*indistinct*
Okay second, oh well, that's the second game point worn by me cousin one game stick to my game
Leading from there
Good point there's a great point. Oh
Who do who do I think it's going to win its win this one?
Both are really good players
At this time oh
That's that's a story point, who are you telling that to
To win four games and this is current two games to one
Okay, it was three games to zero down
Five four greetings from Hungary. Thank you, unfortunately
That's a good one, that's a good great point. Look at this one. Look at this one
What a point Oh
Finland we used to play there Table Tennis like a long time ago in there then we actually met for every six points after six
Points, you can always go to the towel for a short break six seven
Oh
Sorry point you may recover but no six eight for Myka
It's great to have you guys commenting it's
Nine mica sown serves to serves to come
He went for a big
It goes let's see and when it's a Kenton there is a serve one serve
What is 3 point I
Was so lucky
Well, good flip
Good recovery good recovery. Whoa deserving
Well
That was the first time that actually saw autumn moving. I seriously if you really want to keep his beard
Such a big stake in this match, but not new service. That's it Lancers
Great great point and he misses the chop
Alone sir
And then kind of misses are kind of like easy
And he misses 16:14 - oughta
Just think mica is one game away from getting a haircut
Always the oh what a shot
What a shot love you this much
Later this is the match 6-4
Unforced error once again set on 4
For 9 free haircut, I agree
8 who had it come back playing with me. He's giving him some points not deserving
Good what a comeback can I finish it?
Face that's a million-dollar place
Yeah, we're gonna first match point to Otto, okay, we'll see
Oh
Once again ride-alongs here. Oh
He misses it
Vika what
Happened there four games to one. Here we go then
There it goes
There it goes, it's actually looking pretty good
That's good enough, yeah
We actually think like the short hair like suits you quite well, this is all unnecessary here
It's a bit fine touch button. Oh, no, I can see my reflection
It's pretty good from widely then he looks pretty nice a
lot of hair
Sorry, this is my new style. There is
There it was there was quite exciting match though
Well played both of you. Sorry for the
There was a lot of technical difficulties. Yeah
Yeah, but at least you you got to see yeah it live. Yes, pretty nice. I think but yeah, thanks guys
This was the 500k much
Okay. Okay. Thanks guys